bonsoir avec nous cette semaine laurent
wauquiez vice président de l'ump bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous l'ump
dans les militants auront opté pour le
statu quo interne jusqu'en novembre 2015
vous vous distinguez souvent au sein de
votre parti comparé parfois au bal des
ego des ego laurent wauquiez avec nous
au cours de cette émission nadège peljak
belle agence france presse notre
partenaire avec dailymotion
et puis perrine tarneaud de public c'est
darren d'orange rejoindre ont tour à
tour mais avant de parler de l'ump des
rendez vous électoraux et qui vous
attendent et de l'action de la gauche au
pouvoir
cette question est ce que vous aimez les
romans d'espionnage est ce que j'aime
les romans d'espionnage
j'adore les romans d'espionnage sauf
quand il s'applique à l'europe ce qui
est en train de se passer quand même
très triste et c'est surtout très
révélateur de la naïveté et de la
fragilité de l'europe c'est tout et que
les états unis nous espionnent c'est pas
un scoop
alors c'est vrai aussi en béton oui
surtout ce qui est vrai c'est que
l'europe aborde ses relations avec le
reste du monde avec une incroyable
naïveté et une incroyable fragilité on
est divisé nos divisions sont exploitées
par les états unis on est espionné notre
façon d'approcher un dialogue commercial
qui va être stratégique sur les années
qui viennent
visiblement désordre il y a un vrai
problème européen au réveil offert
finalement c'est tout ce qu'on apprend
tout ce qu'on est con sur l'ampleur du
système américain d'espionnage oui mais
c'est surtout pour moi le révélateur que
l'europe est l'homme malade de la
planète et que du coup les états unis en
profite et cette affaire d'espionnage
montre à quel point nos naïveté et nos
points de faiblesse sont exploités par
nos compétiteurs à l'échelle de la
planète est ce que l'europe et la france
doivent passer aujourd'hui un stade
supérieur avec des représailles par
exemple vous avez cité les négociations
commerciales projet pas d'accord de
libre échange asie est ce qu'il faut
annuler ces négociations prévue lundi
je ne vois pas comment est-ce qu'on peut
commencer des négociations commerciales
avec un partenaire qui vous espionne
c'est juste impossible
je voudrais prendre un tout petit point
mettons à l'époque du général de gaulle
vous imaginez ce qu'aurait été la
réaction du général de gaulle en
apprenant que les américains espionné
l'europe et là on n'a quasiment rien on
a un président hollande qui est
quasiment inaudible
il a condamné en termes forts en lisant
ça doit cesser
le taux de casse c'est l'expression
utilise j'ai une doute pas qu' obama
était terrifiée par la prise de parole
de françois hollande on met des
explications alors si on a des
explications tout est bon on peut
continuer méthane ou serait attendu on
espérait non mais ce qu'on attend c'est
immédiatement la suspension des
négociations qu'il y ait des
explications immédiates qui soient
données qu'on ait des éléments objectifs
permettant de savoir si oui ou non les
états unis espionné jusqu'à quel niveau
enfin voilà qu'on n'est pas cette image
lamentable d'une europe qui non
seulement est espionné mais réagit à
peine ou avec des propos diplomatiques
que vous avez retranscrit avec beaucoup
d'ironie et avec beaucoup de justesse
c'est tout ça est un gigantesque cirque
à ce que la france doit renoncer à
acheter des drones américains par
exemple
non c'est pas le sujet si on veut
répliquer c'est ça peut être une réponse
oui enfin si on a besoin des drones
c'est peut-être pas par là qu'il faut
commencer ce qui me semble en revanche
évident c'est qu'on ne s'attaque pas on
enclenchera une négociation avec un
partenaire commercial dans une position
de faiblesse comme l'est la nôtre
aujourd'hui
et pour moi ce qui compte c'est pas
juste la sphère d'espionnage c'est ce
que ça révèle sur une europe qui est en
réalité aujourd'hui une passoire et qui
n'est pas suffisamment capables de se
défendre et de mars ne demande l'asile
politique à la france est ce que d'après
vous ce serait à l'honneur de la france
de l'accueillir
non j'aime pas trop si je n'aime pas
trop cette idée j'aime pas trop cette
idée parce que malgré tout c'est quand
même un citoyen américain qui a été en
violation des règles de loi américaine
l'asile politique c'est pas fait pour ça
il se dit maman oui l'asile politique
c'est fait pour des gens qui sont
persécutés par des dictatures les etats
unis c'est quand même pas la syrie
encore du budget maintenant si vous
voulez bien laurent wauquiez avec le
sévère tour de vis qui est imposé à la
quasi totalité des ministères est ce que
c'est la preuve selon vous que le
gouvernement a décidé de s'attaquer pour
de bon aux déficits
vous me permettez nous répondre très
clairement et simplement on amuse la
galerie
pourquoi est-ce qu'on amuse la galerie
on amuse la galerie avec quelques petits
ajustements budgétaires
sauf que qui a fait l'essentiel de
l'effort jusque là c'est les français
l'essentiel de l'effort d'ajustement
budgétaire a été supportée par des
hausses d'impôts qui ont été sans
commune mesure à peu près
armin et ça maintenant mais dans les
efforts vont porter sur les économes et
ce que je peux vous poser une question
l'année prochaine la tva augmente ou non
elles augmentent qui payent la tva tous
ceux qui les citoyens voilà donc
et alors c'est pas des augmentations
d'impôts sein d'accor la positif a déjà
été votée mais d'autres si elles ont été
programmés ça signifie qu'elle n'existe
pas pour les français si c'est il n'y a
juste pas de parole présidentiel sur
cette question l'année prochaine il y
aura à nouveau des augmentations
d'impôts après un paquet d'augmentation
cette année qui a été un niveau
totalement anormal et donc pourquoi est
ce que je dis qu'on amuse la galerie
parce qu'on amuse la galerie avec les
petits états d'âme de madame bateau
alors que pendant ce temps là les
français les classes moyennes elles sont
saignés à blanc avec des impôts qui sont
dans des augmentations sans commune
mesure
je rappelle 15 milliards d'euros
d'impôts supplémentaires pour les
classes moyennes
30 milliards d'augmentation globale sur
le paquet fiscal l'année prochaine
encore des augmentations par la remise
en cause de la politique familiale où
l'augmentation de la tva
et comme l'a annoncé le rapporteur du
budget socialiste ça ne semble être
qu'un apéritif et il n'exclut pas
contrairement aux engagements qui ont
été pris par nantes de nouvelles hausses
d'impôts mais on nous dit on nous dit
tout ça c'est pour aider les entreprises
1 que l'on soutient avec des mesures
pour la compétitivité est ce que c'est
pour la bonne cause qui est le principal
bénéficiaire du crédit impôt
compétitivité
la poste qui est le deuxième
bénéficiaire du crédit impôt
compétitivité
carrefour donc on demande aux français
d'augmenter la tva de faire des hausses
d'impôts sans commune mesure avec tout
ce qu'on a connu par le passé pour aider
les entreprises très soumise à la
délocalisation à la concurrence
internationale
la poste et carrefour on se moque pas de
nous là alors pendant que delphine batho
parce que vous avez cités ans il faut
s'arrêter quand même elle est convoquée
à matignon après avoir critiqué son
mauvais budget d'écologie des crédits en
recul de 7%
quelle lecture faites vous avez connue
pour les négociations difficiles comme
ministre à bercy pour prendre pour le
budget
elle est dans sa logique propre ou est
ce qu'elle se met à côté du gouvernement
finlandais section des moments qui sont
difficiles pour un ministre parce que
vous négociez votre budget vous négociez
l'ambition de votre politique et
delphine batho visiblement dénonce le
sacrifice de toute ambition écologique
mais ce qui est très gênant c'est que ça
se fait pas sur la place publique
quand on est membre du gouvernement on
est membre d'une équipe et surtout au
moment des arbitrages budgétaires
hélas ce qui est très inquiétant c'est
la cacophonie global qui est en train de
s'installer
si on reprend les éléments les uns après
les autres on a un président de la
république qui nous annonce qu'il n'y
aura pas d'augmentation d'impôts on vise
à montrer qu'il y aurait des
augmentations d'impôts on a rapporteur
du budget qui lui même a contredit les
engagements qui avaient été pris par
jean marc ayrault
on a maintenant une ministre de
l'écologie madame bateau qui dément jean
marc ayrault sur la place publique et
elle est maintenant on vient de
l'apprendre soutenu par madame duflot
des verts qui est elle même membre du
gouvernement et qui expliquent contre
jean marc ayrault que madame bateau a
raison et par dessus tout on a
maintenant les députés verts du
parlement qui se sont exprimés en disant
il faut pas le bateau reste ce qui est
quand même totalement contradictoire
avec ce qu'avait dit françois hollande
10 ans si un ministre ces cartes il sera
sorti du gouvernement est donc ce qui
est quand même pour les français qui
regarde tout ça dans une période
compliquée on leur demande beaucoup
d'efforts où on assume l'essentiel de
l'augmentation fiscale quelle image
donne ce gouvernement en ce moment on a
juste l'impression d'un grand happening
qui est systématiquement sur la place
publique sans aucun cap dans lequel la
parole de jean marc ayrault ps peut dans
lesquelles la parole du président peut
être démentis du jour au lendemain et au
fond il n'y a aucune direction claire
cette cacophonie est très inquiétante
elles vont penser que d'être une bateau
devait quitter le gouvernement je pense
juste que soit elle obtient ce qu'elle
veut se fera il est évident qu'ils aient
enfin il ne peut pas avoir de cohérence
à sortir de la ligne qui est imposé par
son premier ministre et vouloir rester à
l'inter du gouvernement voilà enfin
c'est juste mais je maintiens ce que
j'ai dit tout ceci n'est destiné qu'à
amuser la galerie sans verser dans le
coeur du problème ce sont les
augmentations d'impôts pour les classes
moyennes d'accord sur les périodes deux
représentants
au sein du gouvernement des écologistes
notamment cécile duflot qui demandent
que la politique soit fortement
réaffirmé dans le sens de l'écologie est
ce que eux aussi doivent en tirer les
conséquences et qui paie pas je pense
que chacun son devoir de cohérence
personnelle
la réponse elle est apportée par la
baisse du budget mal un bateau est la
moins 7%
donc c'est clair c'est un sacrifice sur
l'ambition écologique et donc sur la
transition environnementale
c'est un choix qui est fait par le
gouvernement après j'ai envie de dire
soit madame bateau est cohérente avec
elle-même soit madame duflot est
cohérente avec elle-même
auquel cas il faut partir soit ils
préfèrent leur poste soit il préfère
rester dans leur environnement
ministériel et trahir leurs convictions
c'est leur choix
manquant sur le budget il ya quand même
on l'a vu une réduction nette du nombre
des fonctionnaires à quel prévu - 3200
fallait-il aller plus loin selon vous
dans le problème il n'est pas là c'est
que dans le même temps il ya eu des
embauches et qu'il ya des embauches ont
compensé justement et xavier sartre qui
ont été faites dans le secteur notamment
de l'éducation nationale le résultat
c'est que par ailleurs sur les autres
secteurs l'effort qui est consenti est
extrêmement important et pour un
résultat vous l'avez vous même souligné
qui est risible c'est à dire que moins
trois mille deux cents c'est pas comme
ça qu'on va redresser la france mon
inquiétude est liée aux séquences moment
si on est très lucide il n'y a pas de
baisse des dépenses de fonctionnement
pas de baisse la seule économie qui a
été fait pour l'instant c'est sur la
charge de la dette c'est tout et donc ce
qui est en train de faire ce
gouvernement c'est qu'ils sacrifient les
investissements dans l'avenir aux
dépenses de fonctionnement
on continue à avoir des dépenses de
fonctionnement qui ne baisse pas
vraiment et pour ajuster on sacrifie
l'investissement vous l'avez vu avec le
renoncement à la ligne de tgv qui
devaient passer par le centre l'auvergne
est ensuite desservir bianchi est
totalement saturé on le voit avec le
sacrifice des investissements d'avenir
notamment dans nos universités
le budget de l'enseignement supérieur
est vraiment massacrer avec un
renoncement au soutien sur la recherche
et l'enseignement supérieur et donc ce
qui est en train de se faire c'est que
comme on n'a pas le courage de baisser
la dépense de fonctionnement
eh bien on sacrifie l'investissement
c'est exactement l'inversé qu'il faut
faire parce que vous oui est ce que vous
vous réjouissez de la levée de
l'immunité parlementaire de marine
qui était donc voté comme prévu par les
députés européens je rappelle qu'elle
avait dénoncé dans un discours les
prières de rue de musulmans en les
comparant à l'occupation
il faut être très précis à ce à quoi
elle a comparé parce que sinon les
auditeurs qui nous écoutent se disent
bah oui c'est une occupation de rue ce à
quoi elle l'avait comparé c'est l
occupation de la seconde guerre mondiale
et assise et sans char c'est important
pour problème est bien sur quoi est ce
que les propos avaient on les a oubliés
ces propos n'ont où l'on une importance
moi je vais vous dire mon sentiment très
simple sur ce qui est marine le pen et
son positionnement tout ce qui permet de
la victimiser et mauvais tout ce qui lui
permet de prendre des postures disant je
suis une victime de la démocratie parce
que moi je dis les choses alors que les
autres ne le disent pas lui permet de
prospérer et donc ça n'est pas sain et
pas bon pour moi
est ce que ce préféré qu'on puisse
discuter s'agissant m'a même le pen
s'est par exemple son activité
parlementaire
elle est député européen là il ya un
joli thème a évoqué elle est payée par
le parlement européen elle prend son
salaire de député européen est ce qu
elle fait son travail
moi j'invite tous vos téléspectateurs à
aller sur internet et à regarder ce
qu'est l'activité parlementaire de
madame le pen et voir si elle qui est
payé par nos deniers publics fait ou non
un travail de politique elle est parmi
les députés européens les moins actifs
de toute l'europe
je préfère quand on parle de ces sujets
plutôt quand on en fait une victime un
peu facile de la démocratie un mot est
ce que vous estimez se reparler de l'ump
dans un instant avec ma belle fille de
jacques vabre est ce que vous pensez que
nicolas sarkozy est le seul à pouvoir
l'empêcher d'accéder au second tour en
2010 est ce que je crois en tout cas
parce que ça c'est des failles je suis
retombé
je vous réponds très clairement vous
inquiétez pas en 2007 le seul président
de la république de la vème république
qui a fait baisser le fn c'était nicolas
sarkozy
voilà ça vaut pour la prochain silence
il juste un fait et le fait c'est que
nicolas sarkozy est le seul président de
la vème république avoir fait baisser le
score du fn elle est on va parler donc
de la situation à l'ump avec nos deux
fils jack de l' agence france presse qui
nous rejoint d'abord on rebondit sur ce
que vous aviez dit
est-ce que vous avez déploré le problème
de leadership dans votre camp jérôme
rabier partis politiques cherchent un
leader pour 2017
voilà la petite annonce que pourrait
passer l'ump malgré la confirmation
dimanche de jean françois copé à la
présidence du parti
car depuis la défaite de nicolas sarkozy
l'an dernier et le fiasco de l'élection
pour la présidence de l'ump
difficile de voir une personnalité
s'imposer comme cela a toujours été le
cas à droite
la preuve il faudra même des primaires
pour les départager
on le voit pas quels événements
pourraient faire en sorte que d'ici 2015
2016 2017 un leader s'impose contre tous
les autres naturellement et donc les
primaires sont le meilleur moyen pour en
désigner un camp rien ne légitime un
leader particulièrement par rapport aux
autres c'était ce clip qui s'était passé
au parti socialiste
aucun leader n'émergeait de manière
incontestable donc la seule façon de
faire ça a été de faire une primaire
c'est ce qui va vraisemblablement se
produire pour l'ump
le principe de primaires ouvertes acté
la liste de candidats potentiels ne
cesse de s'allonger
jean françois copé et françois fillon
bien sûr mais aussi xavier bertrand
bruno le maire laurent wauquiez valérie
pécresse c'est pourquoi pas alain juppé
toujours plébiscité par les militants à
trois ans de l'échéance les ambitions
sont à peine voilée ce qui amuse les
plus anciens de la famille politique
nous progressons dans la démocratie et
est-ce que des primaires c'est pas le
bal de toutes les ambitions et ça risque
pas finalement fait renaître
oui justement mais après les primaires
comme ça en fait des réductions de la
corse
une sélection qui pourrait s'opérer mais
encore faut-il que ces primaires et bien
lieu car plus d'un an après la défaite à
l'élection présidentielle
la popularité de nicolas sarkozy fait
encore de lui le leader spirituel de la
droite
si sarko revient pas il y aura une
primaire ouverte avec quatre cinq six
candidats parce que le jeu sera ouvert
si sarko revient on verra on pourrait
très bien mais j'ai une situation
exceptionnelle avec le retour d'un homme
exceptionnel auquel nous pensons tous où
quelqu'un est si bien utile le fallait
que le maire en laissant volontairement
planer le doute sur son retour nicolas
sarkozy freine l'ascension d'un nouveau
leader à droite la relève n'a plus qu'à
espérer qu'ils renoncent pour enfin
s'affirmer
un pari risqué vu l' envie d'en découdre
que l'on prête à l'ancien chef de l'état
sur neige en question à laurent wauquiez
tout à fait un pourcentage on vient
d'entendre monsieur jean claude gaudin
le maire de marseille dire nous
progressons la démocratie mais vous même
vous aviez dit dans une interview au
monde c'était le 3 juin je crois que
vous craignez que l'ump n'entrant une
période de glaciation
alors après le scrutin qui vient de se
dérouler là entre vendredi et dimanche
est ce que vous êtes rassuré les
militants avant tout voulu dimanche
écarter une guerre des chefs
c'est bien tant mieux et c'était sans
doute une décision sage
ils ont été à peu près un quart des
militants à s'exprimer mais on a aussi
trois militants sur quatre qui ne se
sont pas exprimés et je crois que ce
serait une grave erreur de voir dans ce
vote un satisfecit par rapport au
fonctionnement actuel de l'ump et j'ai
même vous dire ma conviction très
profonde
la question n'est pas de savoir comme
d'ailleurs vous l'avez poser si c'est
copé ou fillion ou tartempion qui est le
leader de l'ump
la question c'est de savoir quelle est
notre ligne quelles sont les idées qu'on
est juste là vous trouvez que la ligne
n'est pas clairement définie je trouve
que pour l'instant notre ligne n'est pas
clairement définie et qu'on doit
progresser là dessus c'est pour moi le
seul enjeu qui s'ouvre devant nous et
pour beaucoup tourné et être à l'écouté
des militants
je crois profondément qu'aujourd'hui les
militants ne sont pas encore satisfaits
loin s'en faut
du fonctionnement de notre parti mais
l'opposition c'est fait pour ça
l'opposition s'est fait pour se poser
des questions c'est fait pour se
renouveler c'est fait pour apporter des
nouvelles idées nous parliez la
glaciation alors vous devez être heureux
aujourd'hui
non parce que ma crainte est précisément
que dans un accord on met la poussière
sous le tapis
eh bien on ne permettent pas de faire
avancer le débat d'idées se tienne
encore parler vous vous parlez de
l'accord qui faisait qu'il devait y
avoir une nouvelle élection en septembre
à laquelle vous étiez d'ailleurs je
rappelle tout alger non non les riches
en septembre vous la vouliez vous
vouliez qui est un nouveau vote en
septembre et vous aviez bien l'intention
de vous présenter à ce vote
ce qui est inquiétant c'est quoi pour
pour l'expliqué très simplement c'est
que comme on avait une guerre des chefs
et comme on avait un affrontement entre
jean-françois copé et françois fillon
ils ont fait le choix de geler les
positions étant mieux celle ça évite une
déflagration vous avez été lâchés
puisque vous étiez d'accord à ce que je
peux
allez et tout ça c'est très bien parce
que ça a évité la guerre des chefs
mais ça ne résoud rien parce que ça ne
fait pas une politique un compromis une
petite négociation n'a jamais fait digne
politique et donc c'est pourquoi je
plaide c'est quoi c'est pour que après
les européennes comme en son temps
jacques chirac avait su le faire comme
en son temps nicolas sarkozy avait su le
faire
notre parti politique fasse un vrai
congrès dans lequel on définisse notre
ligne politique quelles sont les idées
sur l'europe
quelles sont nos idées sur la question
économique quelles mesures d'économie on
propose quelle ambition pour le pays
comment est-ce qu'on rectifie sociale
pour éviter que ça tourne à l'assistanat
systématiquement quelle est la ligne
politique de l'ump parce que là on a
réglé partiellement en évitant le sens
du conflit entre deux personnes mais
régler un conflit entre deux personnes
ça n'a jamais fait d'une politique et
donc la difficulté pour moi c'est la
ligne politique et ce que j'entends
c'est aussi dans ce vote trois militants
sur quatre qui ne se sont pas exprimés
et qu'on ne se trompe pas ce vote ne
signifie pas un chèque en blanc pour le
fonctionnement actuel de l'ump lisant
vol qui est une page qui se tourne
ils veulent une ligne politique qui soit
plus clair ils veulent plus d'unités
mais autour d'idées qui soit clairement
affirmé moi c'est pour ça que je vais le
vrai et je le je le dis très simplement
plus d'unités à l'inter de mon parti
mais pas sur des compromis à l'eau tiède
pas sur des demies valeur pas sur des
demi propositions pour vous ce vote des
militants de gameplay qui n'a passionné
que nous espérions a compris donc mais
pas une victoire pour jean françois copé
c'est c'est vraiment ça je vais leur
dire très simplement mon sujet pas de
savoir si c'est jean françois copé
françois fillon ou untel c'est pas ma
question
ma question et c'est à ça que je veux
vrai c'est comment l'ump retrouve son
unité pas sur des compromis artificielle
de personnes mais sur des idées des
valeurs
voilà je pense que si on sort quand même
d'un échec électoral
la question qui nous est donc posée
c'est quelles sont les idées que vous
mettez en avant
quelles sont les propositions concrètes
que vous portez c'est ça qui m'intéresse
car l'unité c'est autour de ça que je
voulais construire c'est à ça que je
vais me consacrer renouveler nos idées
même des propositions sur la table et
recréer l'unité de ma famille politique
autour de ce renouvellement de nos
propositions
je comprends bien j'allais justement
vous demander où est ce qu'on vous
situer entre jean-françois copé et
françois fillon qui maintenant vont
mener pouvoir mener leur vie jean
françois copé à l'ump puisqu'il est élu
jusqu'à 2015
sauf si votre idée de congrès en 2014 et
finalement accepté ce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est jamais peut-être
et puis monsieur fillon qui lui a
maintenant créer son parti le forces
républicaines maman il est présent en
france républicaine donc ils
s'organisent autour de son parti alors
vous vous situez comment entre les deux
mois je me situe très simplement je me
situe sur le terrain des idées
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que ma question c'est pas de savoir qui
a gelé les positions c'est pas verdun
tout ça est ridicule
enfin intel avec son micro parle de ses
idées alors c'est à dire c'est la
retraite
vous avez fait des propositions sur les
propositions elles sont très simples
d'abord la première c'est le premier
impératif en france et reconsolider les
classes moyennes c'est le point majeur
de faiblesse aujourd'hui de la société
française on a assommé les classes
moyennes de charge
ce sont elles qui aujourd'hui souffrent
énormément dans la crise économique
notre obsession doit être comment est-ce
qu'on protège les classes moyennes le
deuxième sujet qui est majeure parce que
derrière tout est lié notamment la
compétitivité de nos entreprises c'est
comment mieux faire la différence entre
le social on doit préserver et
l'assistanat qu'on doit corriger
on a un système social qui a évolué sur
la piste de l'assistanat qui aujourd'hui
n'est plus régulé avec beaucoup d'abus
avec beaucoup d'injustices aussi dans
cette influence rc cancer de la société
qu'on vous l'aviez d'une loi leterme
avait choqué parce qu'il ya des gens qui
sont affectées par cette maladie donc
doublement mettait expliqué par contre
le fond je le maintiens totalement je
maintiens totalement que quand dans un
pays la différence entre celui qui
travaille est celui qui ne travaille pas
assez à peine 100 euros c'est pas
possible je maintiens totalement que
l'accès total au système de santé
totalement gratuit est une folie je
maintiens que l'aide médicale d'état
pour des étrangers en situation
irrégulière ne peut pas permettre
ensuite de régler correctement la
politique d'immigration
donc on a une différence à faire entre
le social et l'assistanat
la troisième chose qui est absolument
centrale c'est évidemment l'exemplarité
des politiques comment faire encore
confiance à des politiques alors qu'on a
des affaires à répétition
on en parlera dans la troisième partie
de l'émission avec votre vote distinct
de vos amis je le laisse et le dernier
sujet c'est l'europe sur lequel on
reviendra peut-être l'europe ne
fonctionne plus on a besoin d'europe
mais pas s'être placé ce que vous disiez
ce que vous disiez au début et enfin on
a tous les cas l'impression qu'on est
rentré dans une nouvelle phase
maintenant et qu'est ce que c'est c'est
la bataille de 2
17 qui est lancé c'est rien ne serait
pire
je pense que si on la pression qu'on a
oui je pense que la nouvelle phase qui
s'ouvre c'est on a tourné la guerre il
en a pas tourné la page de
l'affrontement copé fillon et donc ce
dont on a besoin c'est qu'il ya un
renouvellement qui arrive ce dont on a
besoin c'est qu'à l'ump on ouvre un peu
les fenêtres c'est qu'on fasse rentrer
des nouvelles idées c'est qu'il ya une
nouvelle génération des idées des
programmes le renouvellement c'est aussi
de celui des générations c'était un
train de via
non cette direction ça veut dire devenir
des nouvelles idées samuel est ça devait
dire une nouvelle génération
ça veut dire des gens qui sont capables
d'aborder la politique différemment
c'est ça dont on a besoin en ce que vous
serez candidat à la primaire de 2016
alors on adhère généralement des
générations nader renouvellement de
génération j'essaie de m'impliquer à eux
mêmes ce que je préconise
si je suis en train de vous dire que je
trouve ridicules d'ouvrir la page des
primaires maintenant alors qu'on n'a pas
fait notre inventaire dossevi alors dit
pense oui bien sûr que tout le monde y
pense et si je vous dise l inverse je
serais sûrement ne me croirez pas mais
même avec un sourire aussi craquant je
ne vous dirai pas à des jeux plus gras
que je suis candidat à la primaire en
pas maintenant parce que pour moi la
seule question c'est d'abord qu'est ce
qu'on propose qu'est-ce qu'on incarne et
ensuite on verra pour l'instant c'est
j'ai envie de dire pour l'instant on est
dans la phase où chacun doit faire ce
travail de réflexion et de créativité
c'est ça ces idées là vous allez les
mettre en place
vous allez proposer dans le cadre de la
droite sociale puisque je rappelle que
c'est un des cinq mouvements de l'aide
de l'ump que vous avez créé la droite
sociale c'est dans ce cadre là que vous
allez faire ses propositions c'est un
travail et ensuite ça sera
ces propositions seront remises dans un
espèce de pot commun parce que j'ai
l'impression que tout le monde fait ses
propositions un vous monsieur bertrand
nathalie kosciusko morizet valérie
pécresse
chacun fait ses provisions bien en plus
de messieurs fillon et copé bien sûr
mais à la fin que ce qui se passe
mettez tout ça dans un pot commun vous
secouez puis vous sortez un seul qui
sont les meilleurs mais si jack vous
avez parfaitement raison mais pourquoi
est ce qu'ils font le combat vous l'avez
parfaitement ne s'est jamais remontrée
2015 est-ce que c'est pas en 2014 2014
justement
moment c'est finalement on sera à mi
parcours ça permettra de se poser de se
dire voilà on a eu beaucoup de
propositions d'idées
maintenant il faut décanter je voudrais
juste pardon si vous me permettez aller
jusqu'au bout de votre question d'abord
la première si j'aime travailler en
équipe la droite sociale c'est une
équipe de parlementaires c'est avec
cette équipe sait pas très bien comment
terre autour de vous on a une
cinquantaine de parlementaires qui sont
investis au niveau de la droite sociale
et donc l'objectif c'est ensemble de
faire des propositions avec des élus de
terrain qui sont pas souvent des élus
qui sont toujours très médiatisé mais
qui sont des élus qui sont au contact
d'un espèce de bon sens que je crois que
même fait un peu perdu en étant parfois
trop dictée par des cabinets de
communicants parisien donc déjà remettre
un tout petit peu cette approche là sur
notre construction de nos idées c'est le
premier élément
le deuxième élément c'est que moi je ne
va pas refaire ma famille politique j'en
suis fier je la défends j'essaye de la
faire progresser c'est le sens de mon
engagement
donc ensuite évidemment l'objectif n'est
pas d'avoir des petites écuries
j'existe a posées les unes à côté des
autres c'est que ce soit approprié par
le débat commun de notre parti là quand
même
un sujet qu'il faut qu'on aborde c est
nicolas sarkozy vous savez bien que tout
le monde parle de son retour
est ce que vous y croyez vous même
retour de monsieur sarkozy est ce que
vous le souhaitez on c'est important je
vais peut-être vous décevoir là dessus
et pardon mais de la même manière que je
considère que c'est trop tôt pour se
poser ces questions où ces trois
conditions posées à 2017
c'est lui c'est pas le sujet et a posé
ces questions là quand on les rencontre
et qu'il rencontre j'ai beaucoup appris
avec nicolas sarkozy j'ai été pendant
cinq ans au ministre c'est quelqu'un
pour qui j'ai une grande admiration il a
un volontarisme politique extraordinaire
j'ai été dans son équipe dans l'équipe
de françois fillon
donc c'est incontestablement une des
références de notre famille politique
pas là après savoir qu'est ce qui
adviendra dans trois ou quatre ans je
pense que ce qu'il faut maintenant vous
parliez de phases de l'ump c'est que
l'ump se sortent cette obsession de la
tête qu'elle se sortent l'obsession de
savoir qu'est ce qui va arriver en 2017
et qu'elles reviennent juste au fait de
faire son travail
maintenant j'aimerais lui dire il
aiguise il donne tout à l'heure monsieur
sarkozy c'est le seul qui a réussi à
ferrat avait à faire baisser le front
national or on voit que le front
national aujourd'hui se porte de mieux
en mieux
tous les sondages le disent et puis les
élections puisque je prends villeneuve
sur lot par exemple soir
même le ps a été balayé au premier tour
et abordé à mon avis un enjeu qui sera
fondamental pour nous les européennes et
sur lequel je suis un peu préoccupé de
la façon dont on aborde ce sujet parce
que ça va être un point de rendez-vous
notamment par rapport aux femmes les
plus sexy ça va être précisément une
façon de répondre très clairement sur
sur les européennes
j'entends certains chez nous qui
commence à dire on va faire une alliance
avec lui dit c'est exactement l'inversé
de ma conception de la politique
je vais aller jusqu'au bout de ce que je
veux dire c'est monsieur copé c'est à
dire on commence par soi même de s'être
posé la question des idées avant même de
se poser la question de quelle europe
des questions quand même simple mais
fondamentale
jusqu'où l'élargissement est ce qu'on
revient pas plutôt une europe noyau dur
est ce que l'on veut une europe passoire
ou est-ce qu'on refait un peu de
protection notamment européennes
économique c'est la question qu'il se
pose aussi à lui dit on va aller
jusqu'au bout est ce que on continue
avec schengen c'est d'abord ça les
questions qu'on veut qu'on doit se poser
est la question de savoir si vous faites
telles ou telles tractations politiques
avec tel ou tel parti pour gonfler ou
non artificiellement votre score c'est
évidemment pas la première question
la première question que doit se poser
notre famille politique pour quelle
europe on veut vrai dans quelle
direction est ce qu'on veut faire
avancer l'europe l'europe actuelle ne
marche pas qu'est ce qu'on propose en
contrepartie si ça aboutit et si on
approche les européennes
en faisant un petit compromis à l'eau
tiède une petite alliances politiciennes
dernière boutique pour gonfler son score
est à voir à l'arrivée aucun discours
clair sur l'europe je n'en veux pas
m'interroger sur ce que je veux faire
pendant les années qui viennent
c'est précisément éviter que mon parti
ne disent rien qui fasse partie de tout
ce discours politique ambiant dans
lequel on est quoi il ne dirait rien
explique s'allierait avec lui dit
l'udb aussi pensent à l'europe lui aussi
se pose des questions clés parce que
nadège pilsen vous allez faire une
alliance avec un parti avant même
d'avoir réfléchi à ce que vous vous
militez comme vision de l'europe
et avant même d'avoir discuté avec ceux
qui sont en face pour savoir s'ils
partagent la même c'est ça qui est
catastrophique c'est vous faire un point
de vue différent supplémentaire avec
jean françois copé
je veux bien qu'on a on a bien compris
est ce que vous estimez à fond par
nicolas sarkozy
s'cusez moi oui parce que vous le voyez
se soumettre à des primaires puisque ça
ça a été actée par le vote des militants
aussi on oublie pas est ce que vous le
voyez lui en tant qu'ancien chef de
l'état s'il veut jouer leur tour leurs
cours se mêlent pour l'instant on vient
de se doter d'un système qui a été
adoptée dans quel on a des primaires
j'ai envie de dire on va pas alors même
qu'on vient d'adopter un système
commencer à se dire ah bah tiens telle
ou telle option pour ne pas avoir de
primaires pour l'instant c'est pas le
sujet le sujet viendra en temps et heure
je me répète mais la politique c'est
aussi la pédagogie de la répétition
on commence par faire son travail
d'opposition on se remet un peu en cause
sur les erreurs qu'on a fait et on
essaie de progresser sur la clarté de ce
qu'on propose aux français toutes
dernières questions municipales on a
parlé des européennes est loin des
municipales vous croyez à la vague bleue
moi je suis lui en mammeri gelé reprises
à la gauche il ya six ans
c'est une ville qui était qui n'était
pas facile et dans un contexte d'une
vague qui était compliqué je me méfie
toujours quand on prend les trompettes
de jéricho trop tôt donc voilà on fait
d'abord son travail
humble et tranquille et on voit
l'arrivée ce que ça donne merci beaucoup
nadège je devrais être avec nous cette
semaine encore perrine tarneaud public
sénat va nous rejoindre maintenant après
c'était bausch ne portrait de vous
laurent wauquiez on peut vous définir
aussi à travers que les crispations que
vous créez de temps à autre dans votre
camp faustine sa jeunesse c'est un vote
qui lui a attiré les foudres de ses
collègues à l'ump
le 26 juin dernier laurent wauquiez
adopte le projet de loi de la gauche sur
la transparence avec six autres députés
ump contre la consigne de son rôle c'est
sa liberté ans en est en chantier
expliqué il ya une position de
groupe et qui encore une fois est suivi
par 98% des parlementaires c'est un
texte qui n'a rien à voir avec la
transparence et du voyeurisme
c'est de la communication c'est de
détourner les objectifs les projecteurs
qui étaient braqués sur le gouvernement
et la ferc à usak on les renvoyer sur
les parlementaires dernier des aveux en
date une lettre adressée par gérard
longuet est dévoilée dimanche dans le
journal le jdd
le sénateur il exprime son désaccord
total avec la démarche du jeune vice
président de l'ump
pourtant laurent wauquiez n'en est pas à
son premier coup d'éclat vertueux il se
veut le chantre de la transparence
parmi les premiers à avoir dévoilé sa
déclaration de patrimoine
il plaide aussi pour l'abolition des
privilèges des députés et déclenché la
polémique
pour benoist apparu c'est surtout une
nouvelle manière de faire de la
politique propre à leur génération pense
qu'un phénomène que je vais qualifier
générationnel et que beaucoup de jeunes
parlementaires même si tout le monde
n'est pas exactement sur les lignes de
laurent wauquiez est quand même dans
cette volonté de deux fonds de faire de
la politique différemment travailler
différemment après il ya effectivement
d'autres parlementaires comme bruno le
maire ou comme d'autres qui sont sur des
lignes qui sont pas si loin que ça
laurent wauquiez parangon de vertu une
stratégie qui lui réussit plutôt bien
dans les sondages beaucoup moins dans
son camp on lui reproche de trop jouer
cavalier seul on va reparler de de gap
générationnel
bah ouais ce que c'est un effet
générationnel donc cette volonté d'être
plus transparent en tant que
parlementaire ce qui évoquait un instant
benoist apparu dans le sujet vous savez
je me suis engagé en politique à peu
près au milieu des années 90 et on était
comme d'ailleurs toute ma génération
dans ce climat d'affaires nous quand on
a choisi l'engagement politique on l'a
fait en connaissance de cause notamment
sur ce qui est la relation que doit
avoir un politique avec l'argent et
surtout je refuse cette espèce de
fatalité dans laquelle est inscrit une
politique français depuis 30 ans avec un
scandale politico-financier chaque année
je crois pas que ce soit une fatalité
je prends lutter contre transparence à
tout prix vous pensez que c'est la bonne
solution la seule je crois juste que il
ya quand même un certain nombre de
moments où il faut qu'on se pose les
bonnes questions en france
dans n'importe quelle démocratie au
monde vous savez si jamais un
parlementaire à une activité à côté
c'est juste indispensable si vous
conseiller par exemple je sais pas moi
une entreprise immobilière ou si vous
convient vous conseiller une entreprise
pharmaceutique
vous allez voter une loi sur le logement
si vous êtes conseiller de la grande
distribution vous allez voter une loi
sur la consommation
il ya évidemment des conflits d'intérêts
qui ne sont pas acceptables et donc oui
je crois qu' un certain nombre de règles
d'hygiène démocratique qui peuvent
permettre d'améliorer les choses et
quand on regarde les autres démocraties
elles ont toutes adopté au cours des
vingt dernières années des règles en la
matière la france est la seule
démocratie européenne avec la croatie
joue le conseil qui vient d'entrer dans
les pn donc ces festivals c'est on est
au palmarès des démocraties les plus
actives
je dis juste ça n'est pas un sujet
gauche ou droite
si vous accuse de donner un coup de main
du gouvernement je vais vous dire mon
état d'esprit très simple sur cette
question j'en ai assez des petits
raisonnement politiciens sur cette
question nicolas sarkozy a fait
progresser les choses par exemple il a
soumis les lisiers au contrôle de la
cour des comptes c'est un progrès il a
installé un des autos log au parlement
c'était un progrès la gauche permet de
mieux connaître les conflits d'intérêts
c'est un progrès sur ces questions de
démocratie
je refuse la posture consistant à dire
ça vient de la gauche et donc on vote
systématiquement contre celle à 10 q
comment vous expliquer les réticences de
certains se passe à une classe politique
qui essaye de se protéger ou c'est une
question de génération comme on le
disait débute cette interview non je
pense que voilà chacun peut avoir ses
convictions la matière et je comprends
aussi le sentiment d lui de se sentir
agressés par exemple gérard longuet il
dit moi en tant qu'élu je vais perdre
toute mon indépendance toute ma liberté
avec toutes ces nouvelles règles en quoi
est ce que c'est une perte
d'indépendance de devoir juste dire oui
je conseille telle entreprise à côté je
vois pas où est la perte d'indépendance
pardon dans n'importe quel conseil
municipal compte par exemple vous êtes
responsable d'un office de logements hlm
vous ne votez pas les délibérations qui
concerne le fils de logements hlm
c'est juste de la pure hygiène
démocratique donc je ne vois pas à part
dont en quoi est ce que les députés
sacrifierait leur indépendance
en acceptant juste un minimum de
contrôle démocratique on n'a pas eu
assez d'affaires on n'a pas eu assez de
combats violents il en faut
il en faut combien pour qu'on comprenne
globalement que dans une démocratie a
sauvé il faut que l'extrait montre
jusqu'à quel niveau il faut que le sénat
l'a promis non mais bien sûr on peut
dire enfin de la même manière à empêcher
par exemple jérôme cahuzac
enfin on peut toujours dire oui il ya
toujours des il ya toujours des
cambrioleurs et donc ça certains mettent
la police ouais enfin de temps en temps
mettre la police a peut être aussi utile
et donc moi j'en ai assez pour le dire
simplement me payer l'addition pour
tapie pour cahuzac pour dominique
strauss kahn
je considère qu'il ya un travail à faire
pour tirer oxygéner la classe politique
française et se doter juste mais de
règles minimales enfin quelqu'un comme
moi c'est allé assez loin
oui ce que j'ai d'ailleurs reproché et
je voulais arrêter ce qui concerne le
régime des retraites des parlementaires
ou l'institut de ou la présentation au
moment où l'on tende monsieur cahuzac
touchent une prime d'anciens ministres
il ya quand même quelque chose de
choquant là dedans la loi ne l'a pas
supprimée donc je pense que sur ces
questions il ya vraiment un sursaut
démocratique à faire
s'y ajoute un deuxième point qui est
quand même assez important c'est la
question de l'exemplarité des politiques
on a proposé ça renvoie notre échange le
précédent avec nadège pejak avec la
droite sociale une réforme du régime de
retraites consistant à mettre à égalité
tous les français devant la retraite ça
signifie égalité entre le public et le
privé et le fait de faire sauter tous
les régimes spéciaux de retraite et
d'autres mettre fin au régime spécial de
retraite des parlementaires
ah oui parce que j'aimerais ensuite
devant vous en disant que je suis contre
celui de la sncf est con celui d'aider f
mais que celui des députés des sénateurs
est une tout autre affaire et qu'ils
allaient encore sur ce point là oui mais
je pense que c'est juste indispensable
comment expliquer aux français que les
politiques demandent des efforts qui ne
s'applique pas aux mêmes comment
expliquer ça alors justement jusqu'ici
on va jusqu'au bout de cette logique de
moralisation de la vie publique
que pensez-vous de la loi sur le cumul
des mandats est ce qu'il faut limiter le
nombre de mandats mais peut-être
également limitées dans le temps les
mandats alors je me al'inverse sur ces
sujets là je suis assez méfiant pourquoi
d'abord on l'a évoqué il ya un espèce de
contrat si je comprends bien un
politique va pouvoir continuer à être
avocat ou exercer une activité privée
il pourra plus être mère et un petit
contrat ce qui est assez difficile à
contrer leur aussi en la matière il ya
des abus on va aller jusqu'au bout
la deuxième chose est sûre laquelle il
faut bien bien rappeler les points
on a des élus dans notre sentiment est
que globalement ils sont de plus en plus
coupé des réalités terre coupées encore
plus les parlementaires des réalités de
terrain
en n'ayant plus aucun ancrage dans une
réalité de gestion c'est à mon avis une
erreur
troisièmement on est plutôt dans une
période où il faudrait baisser le nombre
d'élus trop de députés trop de sénateurs
autant que l'ensemble des états unis
là ce que va faire la loi sur le cumul
c'est qu'elle veut au contraire
multiplié encore des élus puisque vous
allez avoir encore plus d'élus avaient
parlé d'une question du nombre de
parlementaires que visiblement il ne
tient pas vous me direz c'est pas la
première fois qu'ils ne tient aucune de
ces paroles présidentielles en plus à
devenir non plus ne seront plus les
mêmes en fait oui enfin ça veut juste
dire on aura encore plus débuts voilà et
puis les élus présents vous voulez dire
du fait qu'il ne cumulerait en plus avec
des livres et vous et une enquête que
qui est intéressante prenait dans les
statistiques parlementaire ceux qui ont
un mandat local et ceux qui n'en ont pas
et regarder si jamais ce qu'ils ont un
mandat local sont ou non plus présents à
l'assemblée
vous verrez qu'elle arrive et c'est pas
toujours ce qu'on pense qu'ils ont
l'activité parlementaire la plus
importante
souvent parce que quand en réalité on a
un point d'ancrage local ça oblige à
avoir aussi une réflexion nationale
moi je crois à 100 c'était la conception
de la politique de pompidou qui
croyaient au fait qu'un bon politique
c'est à la fois quelqu'un qui est
enraciné dans un territoire mais
élection m
avec par exemple oui et c'est pour ça
que je pense que sur un sujet comme le
cumul des mandats il faut pas avoir une
vision d'ayatollahs il ya des dérives
qui sont avec une telle ampleur
des tels enjeux des tel budget hrx est
inconciliable avec un mandat national il
ya des collectivités locales qui sont
avec un tel niveau de responsabilité des
telles charges qu'elles ne sont pas
conciliables
al'inverse vous avez des responsabilités
locales sur des villes de taille plus
modeste ou sur des exécutifs locaux qui
sont de niveaux plus modestes qui
peuvent permettre de concilier mes sous
le régime quand même revenir sur ce
point simple on a quand même voté et
noir vient de voter une loi qui autorise
avoir une activité prisée et à linverse
on autoriserait pas un député ou un
sénateur pas continuer à avoir une
activité d'intérêt général et de service
public c'est quand même un peu compliqué
certains parlementaires de gauche
souhaitent re et limité dans le temps
le nombre de mandats ça ça repose sur
une part dont 1 milles encore enfin moi
j'aime pas le politiquement correct donc
je préfère dire les choses exactement
comme ça
sans ça repose sur une grande piste vous
êtes à votre troisième mandat de député
c'est ça donc ça serait peut être le
dernier si l'amendement de certains
parlementaires socialistes étaient
adoptées c'est très juste et c'est tout
à fait exact parce que j'ai succédé à
jacques barré ensuite donc j'ai été
ministre pendant cinq ans et donc là
j'entamerai mon dernier mandat
je crois que la politique ça s'apprend
et je crois que c'est une vaste erreur
de faire croire aux français que on va
improviser des politiques qui vont
rester pendant un mandat ou deux mandats
et qui ensuite vont partir ce qui se
passe dans d'autres démocraties ça
fonctionne très bien sinon c'est
parfaitement faux il n'y a aucune
limitation de mandats par exemple la
démocratie allemande
vous n'avez pas de démo de limitation de
mandat dans la démocratie américaine
vous n'avez pas de limitation de mandats
au royaume uni donc c'est faux la
réalité c'est que c'est une c'est une
espèce d'immunité la réalité du terrain
est un peu différente notamment aux
états unis par exemple pour souvent
quand vous perdez états unis vous ne
vous représentez pas après la
présidentielle
ça vaut aussi pour deux mais juste là où
souvenir c'est quoi c'est que si vous
faites tourner les politiques qui
décident l'administration et je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit un bon service à
rendre ouï-dire l'administration c'est à
dire ceux qui sont fonctionnaires oui
quand il aurait fait la gueule que si
jamais le politique est fragile si le
politique n'a pas un minimum de
stabilité dans l'exercice de ses
responsabilités c'est l'administration
qui contrôle en tout cas si on vous suit
bien laurent wauquiez on comprend que
finalement la transgression en politique
ça permet de servir votre ascension
personnelle
ça passe par la transgression a les
idées au sein de votre propre camp juste
pardon un petit point là dessus à chaque
fois qu'un politique s'exprime on peut
toujours dire oui mais vous faites ça
parce que c'est votre carrière que vous
visez faut peut-être pas exclure aussi
de temps en temps mais c'est aussi
d'avoir envie de bien sûr ambition est
d'avoir vite fait une carrière c'est
j'ai vu l'ambition
j'ai de l'ambition pour moi mais j'ai
aussi de l'ambition pour monter et j'ai
ce que je voudrais dire c'est qu'il faut
pas exclure que de temps en temps quand
un politique s'exprime il exprime
vraiment ses convictions et ses valeurs
sur l'exemplarité
je suis profondément convaincu de ce que
je vous dis je suis profondément
convaincu que si on continue comme ça
tous les politiques seront balayés sur
le social elle qui a été un domaine où
on l'a évoqué angèle on a eu des
affrontements l'assistanat
je suis convaincu que l'assistanat est
un tort que ça décourage les français
qui travaillent et que ça n'aide pas ce
qu'on prétend aider parce qu'on réalise
anvers un chèque pour acheter le silence
des gens oui ça a été très difficile
oui ça a été transcrit
siph mais je vais vous livrer le fond de
ma conviction
le pays va suffisamment mal pour ne plus
se payer le luxe d'avoir des politiques
qui ne disent rien et qu'ils n'ont pas
le courage de leurs idées alors j'ai une
ambition pour votre pays vous l'avez dit
et pour vous même vous l'avez dit
également prêt à nous préciser laquelle
mais mon ambition précisément c'est de
renouveler nos idées je crois que on est
dans un pays qui est aujourd'hui au bout
de son système dans une classe politique
qui est au bout d'elle-même et dans une
droite et un centre qui est quand même
sorti dans un très mauvais état de la
défaite de la présidentielle donc mon
ambition c'est d'apporter un peu de
renouvellement
c'est à ça que j'essaie de me consacrer
et j'ai vu ce que j'ai une rude tâche
ouais on change de sujet j'ai vu que
votre promo de l'ena avait choisi comme
nom comme parrain en alternance mais là
il représente quoi aujourd'hui pour
votre génération et pour la société
d'aujourd'hui
d'abord bien dis simplement il était
venu et donc on avait rencontré et j'ai
un souvenir qui était passé dans quelle
année voilà alors là vous me posez une
colle ça devait être 99 quelque chose
comme ça et j'ai un souvenir assez fort
parce que l'on était étudiant plutôt
assez tristounet on s'était tous min en
costume-cravate assez lugubre
c'était dans un rôle sans lumière et lui
était rentré et avec lui il y avait un
souffle de vie qui était rentrée dans
l'école
il était avec une tenue colorée il était
joyeux il était venu passer un message
qui était de dire soyez heureux de ce
que vous faites et avec un espèce de
charisme naturel qui s'imposait à tout
le monde et j'en ai vraiment repris au
fond cette idée que mais il faut pas
faire de la politique en étant triste et
il faut faire de la politique en
apportant un peu de joie et un peu de
bonne humeur autour de soir vous gérez
pas
mais très bien fait sauter ainsi perrine
merci laurent wauquiez personnes à
parité avec nous cette semaine et la
semaine prochaine à ministre des sports
madame fournée on sera notre invité en
plein tour de france et que légalement à
quelques jours de la publication du
rapport sénatorial sur le dopage qui ne
concerne pas que le cyclisme mais quand
même
bonsoir à tous sa traque
il est la plus grande catastrophe
industrielle de l'histoire du pays
en 127 morts dans l'effondrement d'une
usine textile où se fabriquent des
vêtements que nous achetons dans nos
magasins que s'est il passé depuis qu'en
est il des conditions de fabrication au
canada notamment dans les ateliers de
cuir et bien ce sera le sujet du docu
débat de la semaine soit plus du sénat
le débat présenté par benoît duquesne
dimanche à 10h sur public sénat une
semaine politique et parlementaire passé
au crible de l'image et du
questionnement la compétitivité
maintenant c'est un problème le coût du
travail qui n'était pas un problème qui
n'existait pas et maintenant un problème
la crise écologique est de plus en plus
vivre eh bien on a besoin de changer les
choses et rapidement parlement hebdo
pour ne rien manquer pour te comprendre
c'est vendredi à 17h45
un éco village est un lieu de vie c'est
un lieu de partage et pour moi c'est un
lieu qui devrait se propager pas mon
partout
mais s'il n'y avait rien du tout je fais
c'est la forêt y avait juste un sentier
de petite randonnée ici qu'ils aient 60
cm de large et puis on a commencé à
défricher à couper des arbres à couper
déjeuner à couper des herbes et puis
petit à petit on s'y est implanté le
dimanche il y avait souvent la famille
qui venait avec le grand-père la grand
mère les enfants tout ça pour pourvoir
les indiens si au début on nous appelait
comme ça dans la rue
s'installer dans la forêt vouloir vivre
à contre-courant forcément ça interroge
quand alexis lançons projets
d'écovillages il y a dix ans on a
d'abord cru à une secte il y a même une
enquête
ici les cinq maisons du hameau se fond
dans le paysage
aucune trace de béton tous les matériaux
sont naturels alexis a construit sa
maison lui même avec une idée si elle
doit disparaître
il ne doit en rester aucune trace ou
presque tout doit retourner à la terre
j'ai coupé les arbres
j'ai fait les plans ce avec une scie
mobile on a fait le statut ravec
et puis on a rempli en bottes de paille
la paille c'est l'isolant parce que
c'est un des meilleurs isolants mais
c'est ça c'est de la paille de sida
paille de blé
on peut utiliser d'autres pas et enfin
moi j'ai fait le choix de la paille de
blé et elle est dans les murs et dans le
plafond qui sait que la paille isole
parfaitement stockent la chaleur ou la
fraîcheur en fonction des saisons
écologique et surtout pas cher parce que
la paille c'est en déchets agricoles
contrairement au point il ya des essais
qui ont été faits en laboratoire sur la
paille et les bottes de paille ils sont
allés au lance flammes
il ya des tanks ont été calculés avant
justement que ça access désagrège
complètement et tout mais ce à ceux
conçus par rapport à une maison
conventionnelle empare pas une maison en
paille mettra beaucoup plus de temps à
être détruites par le feu
contrairement aux idées reçues les trois
petits cochons donc même si la paille
c'est pas très cher le coût de la maison
est quand même important que c'est plus
important que pour une maison
conventionnelle parce que ses pattes et
techniques qui sont encore très connu
c'est pas des techniques très connu mais
il ya quand même une grande partie des
matériaux qui sont qui peuvent rester
cher parce que c'est pas des matériaux
qui sont vendues en très grande quantité
comme le le parpaing ou le ciment et
puis et puis il ya de la beaucoup de
main d'oeuvre
donc cette main d'oeuvre aussi peut
revenir très cher depuis quatre ans
alexis construit sa maison un peu chaque
jour et elle n'est pas tout à fait
terminé encore une vie en chantier qui
se construit lentement
c'est vrai que quand je suis énervé un
peu stressé c'est vraiment très agréable
de venir passer un petit moment ici
d'une part pour regarder pour pour
apprécier voir s'il n'y a pas de
graminées qui sont venus envahir ces
graminées je suis désolé mais je leur
laisse pas la place un jardin en hauteur
que tous les habitants cultivent sur
leur toit s'est inscrit dans la charte
du village on est parti sur l'idée de
dire si on rendait à la terre la surface
qu on lui prend donc de mettre des
plantes et des herbes et tout ça sur la
surface de la maison et puis bon
l'avantagent des toits végétalisés fait
des problèmes de condensation aussi ça
évite la condensation dans la maison
mais il a fallu s'accrocher pour que le
éco-hameau voit le jour des années de
luttes administratives qui ont fini par
en décourager certains
thomas et sa femme ont racheté le
terrain d'un couple qui a quitté le
projet aussi ont vécu en ville
eux aussi ont eu envie de rompre de fuir
une vie qu'il ne maîtrisait plus envie
d'autre chose pour eux et pour leurs
filles
on n'a pas vécu à les enfants ville on
arrive à la campagne avant heureusement
mais quand on y va on n'a pas les
réflexes dans un premier temps les à
face bad à côté de nous et puis on se
rend vite compte qu'ils ramassent des
mégots par terre qui en masse plein de
choses on se dit bon qu'est ce que je
fais
je lui interdis ce que je lui interdis
pas à la maison ça c'est compliqué et
alors qu'ici bon même si elles mêmes
tout noir plein de terre ou debout
graff l'habitat écolo permet de dépenser
moins c'est ce qui est dans l'air du
temps
mais pour thomas et mathilde ce n'est
pas ce qui compte c'est des gens qui se
tourne aujourd'hui vers l'éco
construction c'est aussi par cet
argument économique j'en suis très
content simplement il faut se méfier
quand même de ce que cette économie qui
va engendrer
à savoir tout l'éco business des
matériaux qui vont à nouveau être
transformée et où il va y avoir des tas
d intermédiaire qui vous permettre
d'accéder à une maison écologique
c'était pas ça l'idée non plus ici c'est
pas du bois raboter c'est du bois brut
de sciage c'est de la paille brut de
deschamps essaie de la terre locale
également pour faire le torch
le pari c'est celui de cohabiter
ensemble et de vivre en harmonie avec la
nature
l'autre voisine sur laquelle tout le
monde veille alors comme une évidence
les habitants font en sorte de rendre à
la terre une eau propre grâce à un
bassins plantés de roseaux et d'iris
c'est les plantes elles mêmes qui se
nourrissent de l'eau et qui en même
temps récupère les rues que faire ce qui
est
les cochonneries qui sont dans l'eau